PROFESSOR: Hey, everybody.
Welcome to 6.849, Geometric
Folding Algorithms.
I am Erik Demaine.
You can call me Erik.
And we have as TA Jayson
Lynch, who's right there.
And this class is a bit
unusual, at least for me,
because I'm trying for the first
time a new experiment, which
is inverted lecturing.
And I wrote this on the
poster for the class,
and everyone started asking
me, what's inverted lectures?
Well, it's not a new idea, but
I've never tried it before.
The concept is to make these
in-class times, where we're
all here together,
more interactive
by taking the lecture component
of the class, which is covering
all the material into videos
that you watch online.
So this class is basically
going to alternate
between real in-person things,
as you are here-- of course,
we are also being
video recorded,
so slightly a
contradiction in terms--
but that's for the
people in the interwebs
to be able to watch this.
So we'll alternate between the
real in-class part and video
lectures from the
last time I taught
this class, which was fall 2010.
So this is actually
what the course web
page looks like
as of an hour ago.
So we've got these-- L01,
L02, L03-- those are lectures.
That's content, lots
of material packed
in there, which is how I'm
used to teaching a class-- put
as much material as
I can for a lecture.
Those are already available.
You can start
watching those videos.
Lecture one is optional.
I'm going to basically cover a
shorter version of that today.
It says right there, optional.
Then the Cs, which
don't exist yet,
because we're
doing it right now.
The Cs are the in-class
sessions, the contact hours.
Some of those may be
recorded, like this one,
we're going to record.
But some will not be, and
you need to attend both.
So you've got to
watch the videos,
and you've got attend
all the classes.
That's the set up.
So this is a bit unusual, so
I'll spend a few more minutes
on how this class is formatted.
So-- requirements.
We've got-- watch
video lectures.
I'll talk a little bit
about timing of that.
And then we've got
attend classes.
And then to the actual
material, a regular part
of the class that
you'll be graded on
consists of two parts:
problem sets and a project.
The project also
has a presentation.
This is a project focus class,
so the bulk of your grade
is based on the project
and presentation.
Project can take on
many different forms.
This is a theoretical
computer science class,
so there's the typical
kinds of projects, like,
to read a bunch of papers and
summarize them, survey them.
Though we ask that you
keep them disjoint,
more or less-- avoid
stuff that is well
covered in this book,
Geometric Folding Algorithms,
or in the class itself.
But otherwise you
can survey material.
In addition to the
standard survey paper,
or instead of a
you can write a bunch
of Wikipedia articles
about folding stuff.
So where survey stuff
should be new material
that you haven't
seen, Wikipedia stuff
could be material that
you've seen in this class
but is not well
covered in Wikipedia.
And that will help take over
the world, our usual goal.
If you see a cool
algorithm, in this class
you could implement
it if you're a coder
and see how it
actually works, make it
demoable, which will be fun.
Or you can work on
an open problem.
So if there's
interest, we'll run
an optional open problem-solving
session, where we'll all
get together and try
to solve open problems.
I might also do them
in these class times,
because now we have a lot of
freedom to be more attractive,
to actually fold paper
or to have fun in class.
And instead of me trying
to pack as much material
as I can-- because
that's already
been done in the videos-- you
could pose an open problem.
Especially if you come
from another field,
you may have some interesting
folding-related problems.
Those could be really cool.
Or you could build something,
a physical sculpture,
physical structure of
some kind, furniture,
architecture, whatever.
Or you could do it
in a virtual world
and just design
something interesting.
Though there you might
want to do more than one,
make it harder for yourself.
All of these are
possible projects.
There's a lot of different
options for different types
of people, different
backgrounds, whatever.
Then we'll also have problem
sets, which are weekly,
roughly, and they
shouldn't be too long.
And they will also
have an option
of not doing all the problems.
So every problem
set will probably
have the rule that
you can drop, we
will drop the
lowest grade on one
of the problems that's
on the problem set.
So that means if you just
don't want to do a problem,
you can skip it
and your grade will
be determined by the others.
If you want you could
try to do all of them,
and we'll just drop
the lowest grade.
So if there's some problems
are easier for you,
harder for others,
you can mix and match.
Cool.
There's a lot more details
about this stuff on the website.
If you click on
Project, you'll get
lots of details about these
different styles of project
implementation-- survey,
open problems, whatever.
Because what I said
was pretty brief.
So look at that
for more details.
Project, you don't have
to worry about right away,
but one of the luxuries
of having video lectures
is you could skip
ahead a little bit
to see what looks
interesting to you
and work on a project
related to that.
I wanted to briefly show you a
little bit about this website
and how it works, so
you get a flavor for it.
So let's say the
very next thing you
should do, right after you
leave here, sometime between now
and noon on Monday, you
should watch lecture two.
So you can just click on
lecture two here on the left.
And this is the way it's set up.
You could zoom to fit
everything on your screen.
On the upper left
you've, got your video.
And this should start playing.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-All right, welcome
back to 6.849.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Hey it's me.
I'm even wearing
the right t-shirt.
I had a coincidence.
The fun thing about these
videos, as a few nice features.
One is as you jump
around in the video,
you see the slide down here
in the lower left updates
to whatever I'm covering.
And also if I jump farther,
the page handwritten
notes that I'm covering
on the right changes.
So as I scrabble around, I think
is the term-- too many buttons.
Who designed this website?
All right, I forgot this.
Reload.
So to jump around.
I'll turn down the volume.
You can also speed up the video.
This can be pretty entertaining
if you go really fast.
But you can go 1.1, 1.2,
that's pretty comfortable.
1.5.
Yesterday I listened to a video
to at 2x. it's interesting.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-In general, when
I make that fold,
it might come out of here.
I'd have to wrap around
that [? cone ?], sometimes.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Thankfully, I do
not sound like a Chipmunk.
But if you haven't seen lecture
before, it's a little harder.
But I'll be watching
the lectures with you,
experiencing the same
total number of hours
you have to experience,
So we're in this together.
Let me know if you have any
comments on the website.
It's all been done by
hand, so if there's
anything you want changed,
it's easy to change.
You can also do fun things.
Like when it's paused,
you can jump around
in pages on the right and
say, oh, yeah, I didn't really
understand that page.
And you click on
this time, and it
will start playing
from that time.
At full speed.
We could slow it
down, too, which
can be pretty entertaining.
Anyway, you get the idea.
Let me know how it goes.
I want to make it
as easy as possible.
In fact, if you don't
like my software,
you can just skip it
all, download this video,
like 720p version
or the 360p version.
Play it in VLC with whatever
fancy speed up, speed downs,
you want to use, or put on your
iPad or other tablet, whatever.
This page should
work on an iPad,
but I haven't tested it lately.
If it doesn't, let me know.
Cool.
So that's what it looks like.
And then at the
top of this page,
you see here a link
to completion form.
When you finish watching the
video, you click on this form.
It's pretty minimal.
You enter basically
your name, your username
or your email address, you
say yes, I watched the video,
and then that's all that's
required, you click Submit.
But we highly
encourage you to say
what you think at this point.
If you have any questions about
the lecture, that wasn't clear,
or anything you
didn't understand.
Or I a briefly mention something
that sounded cool to you,
and you want to
know more about it.
This is your chance to
influence what I cover in class,
and this is why
you have to submit
this form by noon
the previous day.
So watching video lectures
and filling out that form
is due by noon on
Mondays and Wednesdays,
the day before class.
That will give me 22 hours
to prepare class, which
should be enough,
we'll find out.
And so I can adapt
the in-class time
to be whatever people
care about most.
So it's kind of like a poll.
If lots of people say I didn't
understand x, I will cover x.
If lots of people are curious
about y, I will cover y.
So whatever you
want to know about,
typically related things, but
if you have unrelated things you
want to bring up as well,
feel free to put it in there.
And we'll try to schedule it in
when it's time or when it fits.
Yeah, that's the plan.
I've never done this before,
so if you don't like the form,
tell me.
Anything you don't like or think
should change, just send email.
Or put it in the form,
but email's good, too.
Question?
AUDIENCE: I noticed
you have a "no" option.
Is that for, like, oh,
shoot, it's 11:45 on Monday,
and I haven't watched this.
Should I still submit
the form and say, "no?"
PROFESSOR: Interesting.
You're so honest.
Why would you fill
out "no" on this form?
I guess so.
You can fill out the
form multiple times.
So you could you could say
no and give your excuse here,
if you want it.
I'll watch it tomorrow,
maybe, and then
later on fill it in with yes.
So in particular, if
you also have questions,
like you watched the video
early on and then later
on you have a question about
it, if it's still before class
time, feel free to
fill this out again.
It just makes another
entry in our table.
This is a Google form.
Another question?
I guess that's
the reason for no.
Maybe also we couldn't
put a single option.
No, it's to force you
to claim, honestly.
This all honor
system, right, so this
is like forcing you to make
a decision to be dishonest,
I guess.
Or to be honest, rather.
Cool.
To make this work, you've
got to ask questions,
you've got a request topics.
Otherwise I'll just fill your
class times with more material.
That would be my
natural temptation,
so you've got to hold me back
and ask lots of questions.
One particular request
I wanted to highlight
is to send me cool
things to cover.
In particular, you
all surf the web.
And if you see cool
folding things, or any kind
of folding-related thing,
on the web, send it to me.
By email.
And the plan is to do one
a day, or maybe two a day,
for in class time.
There's lots of fun
things out there,
and it's hard to see it all.
So when you discover
things, tell
me and I will schedule it
in throughout the semester.
You can think of this as a
standing homework problem.
You should do it sometime
before the end of semester.
Another experiment.
I think to be fun.
That is the end of the
class organizationally.
Unless there are any questions
about requirements or style
or format.
Then in the rest of this class,
I'm going to cover, as I said,
a short version of
lecture one, which is just
an overview of the whole class.
So I want to give you a flavor
of what the course is about,
what kind of theorems we
prove, what kind of algorithms
we develop, so you can
decide whether you are
interested in this class,
whether to take it.
There is also a
survey that, where
you put your name,
email address,
will add you to
the mailing list.
And I announce every
lecture, so if you're
listening to the
class, you just want
to listen to things
you're interested in,
come to class for
interesting things,
just listen to that email and
see when cool things come up.
And also there's a little
survey on that piece of paper.
Does anyone not have
the piece of paper?
Couple people, so we
will get them to you.
A little survey just
to get your background.
There's no required
background for this class,
because lots of people
come from different areas.
Hopefully, you know at least
one of the background areas,
but anything can
kind of be filled in.
And one of the points
of this questionnaire
is if there's something
you don't understand, like,
oh, gosh I should
know XYZ algorithm,
and you assumed it in
lecture, but I don't know it,
could you cover it?
And if enough people
request that, I will.
So that's the format.
Out of curiosity, how many
people here are a course six?
And how many people
are course 18?
And how many people are other?
OK.
So reasonably balanced.
A lot of 6, though.
So we are talking about
geometric folding algorithms.
So there's geometry,
there's folding,
and there's algorithms.
Algorithms are how we compute
things at least theoretically,
and in general what
this field is about
is both mathematics
and computer science.
Say, the mathematics
and algorithms
that underlie how things fold.
And the technical term for
things is geometric objects.
And we're interested
not only in how
they fold, but also
how they unfold.
In general, you have
some geometric structure
they can reconfigure,
like, my arm here
can reconfigure in
interesting ways.
We want to know-- what are all
the ways they can reconfigure,
what all the way it could fold?
This piece of paper is
another geometric object.
We want to know what all
the ways that it can fold.
Before I talk about more
formally what this means,
I want to show you that
folding comes up everywhere,
pretty much.
Almost any discipline
you can name,
there's some, if it involves
physical things at least,
has geometric objects.
Geometric objects
tend to comply.
Even if you're working with
completely rigid objects,
you don't want them to fold.
That's a folding problem.
So I have here a list of a bunch
of different application areas,
and I'm going to show you some
pictures and videos related
to them.
So the first one is robotics.
So if you have things
like a robotic arm,
it starts in one configuration.
You want to continuously
move it to reach
some other configuration,
so it can pick up somebody,
drop it off over here.
I want to know,
how should I plan
the motion of my robotic arm?
A different kind of
robotic application
is to make sheets of
material that are themselves
robots that told
themselves into origami.
This is a self folding sheet
developed by collaboration
with MIT and Harvard.
And you just send a little
bit of electrical current.
These little metal
pieces heat up,
which causes them to pull
the creases shut, and, boom,
you get your origami boat--
with no origamist required.
The same sheet can fold
into many different shapes,
and the underlying
algorithm here,
or the underlying
mathematics, is
that this pattern of
creases, square grid
with altering
diagonals, can fold
into essentially any shape
that is made out of cubes.
Here we're making a paper
plane out of the same sheet,
sending it different signals.
It does not fly but
probably floats.
So that's the idea.
And you can imagine a
sheet like this could just
be arbitrarily reprogrammed
to fold into this gadget,
so I don't have to bring
around so many gadgets.
Maybe my laptop
could fold smaller,
and later could unfold in
something to my desktop.
And I don't know, my
phone could reconfigure
into something else.
That's the vision.
This is what we call
programmable matter, where
you can change shape.
In the same way that
we program software,
we want to be able
to program shape.
Obviously, we're just
getting there now.
So that's robotics.
Next up is graphics.
One example is you want
to animate a character
from one position to another.
That's a key frame animation
that's a folding problem.
I have here an example of
the two dimensional analog,
where you have one polygon
and another polygon,
and you want to
morph continuously
from one to the other.
And these animations
are all found
by algorithms that are
motivated by folding stuff
that we will cover
in this class.
And that's not so easy, but
it's lots of fun things.
All of these motions
avoid collision,
and they approximately preserve
the edge lengths, also,
if it's possible.
If they match on the
left and the right,
they will preserve
those edge links.
So that's graphics, morphing.
Mechanics motivated a lot of
mechanical linkage problems.
In particular is this
great book from 1877
called How to Draw
a Straight Line.
You may think you know how
to draw a straight line,
but the point of this
book is to figure out--
by turning a circular crank,
can I draw a straight line?
And this is motivated by steam
engines, where you have a steam
piston is moving up and
down in a straight line,
and you want to turn
a wheel on your train.
So how do you do that?
Well, these are two
old ways to do it,
and here's what they look like
this in computational land.
These are the original drawings.
So we have on the top a design
by Watt, the unit, in 1784,
and it's approximately straight.
It's not perfect, but this
highlighted point moves
along a circle,
and the green point
moves along the figure eight.
And the figure eight is fairly
straight here in the middle.
So if you just use that
part, it works pretty well.
You lose a little
bit from the wiggle,
but it was used in a lot
of locomotive engines.
Down here, you have the
first correct solution
by [? Percy ?] in 1864,
almost 100 years later,
and if you move the highlighted
a point along the circle,
this point moves
along the red line.
And there's a whole bunch of
mathematics related to this,
generalizing this result, and
we will cover it in this class.
Next up, we have manufacturing.
This is a fun example of
bending a piece of wire.
This is a machine called DIWire,
do-it-yourself wire bending.
So you can build one
of these machines.
Here, it's making
a planar shape.
You can also make
three-dimensional shapes.
Lots of things are possible.
This is a recent machine.
There's actually a
lot of wire bending
machines that are out there.
This is a nice and simple one.
But can you make everything?
No, because this piece of
wire can't collide with itself
and can't collide
with the machine.
That's a constraint.
And you want to figure out,
what shapes can you make?
Can I make my pair of glasses,
or am I limited somehow?
That's a folding problem,
which we will talk about.
Next up, medical.
So one example of a
medical application
is to build a stent.
This is called an origami
stent, developed at Oxford
about two years ago.
And the idea is you want to do
non-intrusive heart surgery,
so you want to take
this big thing,
fold it down really small,
like this, and stick it
through some small blood
vessels in your body
until you get up near
your heart where you've
got nice big vessels
you want to de-clog.
And so you want to expand it
back out to its larger size.
So it's essentially a
transportation problem.
You want to make
something small,
until it gets where you need
it, and then you make it big.
That's one example of
a medical application.
Related to that kind of
transportation problem,
you also have
motivation of aerospace.
So you want to send a
large object into space,
and your space shuttle
isn't big enough to do it.
You'd like to fold it
down to become smaller.
This is an example by Robert
Lang, who is pictured here,
leading origami designer.
And this is a prototype.
It's only five meters in size.
The goal is to make 100-meter
telescope lens, which
definitely does not fit
in your space station.
So you do lots of
foldings like this,
until it fits in
your space shuttle.
Send it out.
When you're in space,
you've got lots of room,
and you can unfold out.
And you get your giant lens,
much larger than Hubble's lens,
for example.
In general, this area is
called deployable structures,
when you want to make something
small for transportation.
Then we have biology.
Protein folding
is a big problem.
A lot of people work on it.
And a protein folds kind of like
a robotic arm, geometrically.
It's a little different , and
it's not fully understood how
it works.
But there's a lot of cool
folding problems, geometry
problems, that we've studied,
motivated by how proteins fold
and figuring that out.
Applications, things
like drug design,
you want to kill a virus
without killing the host.
Design a proteins that
folds into the right shape,
so it kills one thing
and not the other.
That's the sort of general
goal, and have some cool things
which we will cover in
this class related to that.
Next is sculpture,
and origami design
is an obvious motivation
for why you might be here.
This is why we initially
got interested.
Origami has reached
incredible heights.
Both of these are folded
from one square, no cuts.
So just one square paper, you
can make a three headed dog.
You can make, I guess I
shouldn't call him a man,
but you can make a
Nazgul on his horse.
Or is it one entity?
I don't know.
But it's one square
paper, that much I know.
This is designed
by Jason Ku who's
the President of the origami
club at MIT, OrigaMIT, which
you should all check out.
They meet on Sundays at 3:00.
I know there's a bunch
of origami people here.
So how are these possible?
These are possible through
mathematics and kind
of algorithms that we
will cover in this class.
In fact there, is
a guest lecture
by Jason Ku, which you'll
be watching, I think,
in lecture six.
And he's not actually
in town, but still he
can give the video lecture,
because he already gave it.
It's like time travel.
I have just a few examples
of some of our sculpture.
This is with Martin Demaine,
who's your cameraman here.
And these are based on
curve creases, which
we may talk about to some
extent in this class.
And we didn't talk about
it too much two years ago,
but a little bit.
Curve creases are not very
well understood mathematically.
Almost everything we will cover
is based on straight crease
design, like most origami.
Curve creases are
pretty amazing, though.
They do some really cool
shapes, and we're still
trying to figure them out-- how
to design them algorithmically.
These pieces are
on display in DC
right now if you want
to check them out,
for the next several months.
These pieces of paper are
circles with a circular hole,
and there's more than one.
This has two pieces.
This has three.
This has, I think, five.
OK.
So that was a brief
sculpture origami design.
Lots of different other possible
sculptures, kinetic sculpture,
you might want to try building.
Also architecture,
reconfigurable architecture.
I think this is an
underexplored area.
How many people here
are from architecture?
A few.
You might want to make some
reconfigurable buildings.
Hoberman is one example of
someone embracing this a lot.
He started in
folding toy design,
but now he does mostly
folding architecture.
This is one example, from his
company Hoberman Associates,
from the winter Olympics
in Salt Lake City 2002.
It's very dramatic.
You have this folding structure
they can almost completely
close up, except for
a little circle here,
and when it opens up,
you've got this huge stage.
You can see the
scale, of people.
He co-designed this
giant U2 stage.
If you've seen U2 any time in
the last few years, like I did.
This incredible
folding structure
is based on similar principles.
And Chuck Hoberman is
actually teaching a class
at the Graduate School of Design
at Harvard on Monday afternoon,
and I think anyone's welcome
if you want to check it out.
You should go see it.
Talk about his techniques.
Maybe we'll get them
to do a guest lecture.
We'll see.
So that was a brief
overview of a bunch
of different applications.
There's tons more.
In fact, if you have more,
please send them to me.
I know a bunch more,
and we will get to them,
but this is a little
survey of different fields
that folding touches on.
Now I'm gonna switch over to
more mathematical stuff, which
is the bulk of the class.
Unless there are questions?
Cool.
So we move to what
kind of things
we're interested in, in folding.
There are essentially
three types.
Linkages, which we
usually think of as one
dimensional structures.
So we have one dimensional,
usually straight segments,
connected together at
hinges, and here I've
drawn it in two dimensions.
It could also live
in three dimensions.
Like-- my arm is made up
of one dimensional bones,
and then there's
sockets for them
to join, essentially
universal joints.
How can those things fold?
What shapes can they fold into?
General constraints
here are that the edges
should stay the same length--
I can't stretch my arm longer--
and they have to stay
connected at the joints.
I can't detach my elbow
and later reattach it,
at least not ideally.
The mathematical version
is you're not allowed to.
One dimension up, we have
sheet folding, which we usually
refer to as paper
folding, but it
could be sheet metal, anything.
You have your sheet
of material, and you
want to fold into things like
origami, like space stations,
like telescope lenses, whatever.
General rules here.
Like this piece of paper,
you cannot stretch the paper.
It can't get any longer.
It can't collide with itself,
and you can't tear the paper.
You're not allowed to
cut it, because that
tends to make things too easy.
So the sort of
mathematically pure version,
and also the modern
origami pure version,
is that you're not allowed
to cut your piece of paper.
So just folding, no
stretching no crossing.
If you want to go
another dimension up,
we typically call this
polyhedron folding.
So a polyhedron is made up of a
bunch of polygons, like a cube.
And typically we're interested
in unfolding a polyhedron.
So think of this as just a
surface that's hollow inside.
If you wanted to
build that surface,
you'd like to find a shape,
like this cross, that
folds into that cube.
Because if you have
sheet material,
you want to start from
some original shape that's
flat that can fold
into your shape.
You can also consider
the reverse problem,
which is folding.
Suppose I give you this cross,
what shapes can it fold into?
And we've looked
at both, and I'll
talk about them in a second.
So in general, for each
of these categories,
and you'll see these
categories over and over
because they're on the book.
Here it says linkages,
origami, and polyhedra.
And there's three
parts to the book.
There's linkages,
origami, and polyhedra.
Part one, part two, part three.
It's just like this.
Our class will not follow
this order, though.
After today, I think we'll
talk about paper for a while,
then go to linkages
for a while, then
go to polyhedra for a while,
and then we'll repeat,
go to paper for a
while, and so on.
Different parts will be of
interest to different people,
so we'll do lots of
different coverage.
But I think paper's the most
exciting, so we'll start there.
In general, for
each of these types
of things you want
to fold, there
are two kinds of problems
we're generally interested in.
And based around the
idea that, well, there's
some folding structure
that you're interested in,
and then there's
the way it can fold.
And you can start
from either one.
If you start from a
folding structure,
and you want to know
what it can fold into,
this we typically call
a foldability problem,
or you could call it
an analysis problem.
I have something
like this, and I
want to know what
it can fold into.
That's an example.
What can the cross fold into?
Or I have some linkage,
and I have a robotic arm.
It's already fixed.
I've already designed
it, built it.
What shapes can it fold into?
The reverse problem is a design
problem or synthesis problem.
So there I start with what
foldings I would like to have.
So for example, I want
to fold the butterfly.
So I design a butterfly,
and then I'd say,
well, I have a rectangle paper,
can I fold it into a butterfly?
So that's a design problem.
Here you want to design
a folding structure that
achieves your goals, like shape.
So that's generically
what we like to do.
And then there's three types
of results we typically get.
I'm giving a super
high level first,
and then we'll get to
some actual examples.
So these are typical results.
So three types are universality,
decision, and hardness,
and these relate to
what is possible.
In particular, is
everything possible?
And this makes sense both
from a foldability standpoint
and from a design standpoint.
If I give you a robotic
arm, I'd like to know,
can it folding to all the
possible configurations,
or are there some
that it can't reach?
That, if they can
reach all of them,
we have a universality result.
Typically when you can prove
that you can make anything,
you actually get an
algorithm to do it.
So you could say, oh,
well, how do I fold into x?
Well, here's how you do it.
There's an algorithm to
compute that for you.
Also, in design,
I'd like to know,
OK, I can make a butterfly,
and I can make a Nazgul.
Can I make everything?
If yes, you get a
universality result.
That's a design universality.
If universality is not true,
if you can't make everything,
the next best thing
you could hope
for is a decision
algorithm, an algorithm
that tells you quickly, is this
possible, is this impossible.
So this is like a
characterization
of what's possible, and what's
impossible using algorithms.
Sometimes, though,
that's not possible.
There is no good algorithm
to tell whether something's
foldable, and then
we aim for hardness
result to prove that
there is no good algorithm
to solve your problem.
So that gets in
complexity theory.
Not everyone's
going to know that.
We will be reviewing it
in the video lectures,
and in here as needed.
So those are the sort
of typical outcomes
for any of these
kinds of problems.
Let's see some
examples, unless there
are generic questions
at this point,
only generic questions
about generic material.
Next we'll get to
specific material,
and you can ask
specific questions.
So first up is linkages.
And, of course,
there's lots of results
in each of these fields.
I'm just going to show
you a couple in each.
And the first question
you are typically
interested in about a
linkage is, is it rigid?
Does it move it all?
Let me give you some
examples of this.
Do a little pop quiz.
It's OK to get it wrong.
Just makes for some
fun interaction.
So, yes or no, is this rigid?
Or, rigid or flexible,
I should say.
AUDIENCE: Rigid.
PROFESSOR: Rigid.
Everyone agrees.
Good.
Correct.
Rigid or flexible?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Flexible?
PROFESSOR: Depends
on the dimension.
Very good.
It's rigid or flexible.
It depends.
It's rigid in 2D, because
these are triangles.
But it's flexible
in 3D, because you
can rotate one triangle
around this hinge.
And this is rigid or flexible?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Flexible.
Everyone agrees and is correct.
In general, given a
structure like this linkage,
you want to know, is it
rigid or is it flexible?
This has lots of applications.
Like, you want to
build a bridge,
you don't want it to move.
You're building a building,
So here's the mathematical
state of affairs.
Distinguishing this boundary,
which is a rigid in 2D
versus flexible in 2D, we
understand super well as
great algorithms to do it.
We will cover them.
This boundary between rigid
in 3D and flexible in 3D,
we don't really understand.
And there aren't great
algorithms to solve it.
It's a little disconcerting
given the number
buildings and
bridges we live in,
but that's the
state of the world.
And we will talk about all that.
So that is rigidity.
Next up we have universality.
So this is the robotic
arm question I mentioned.
I have a robotic arm.
Does it fold into
everything, into
every possible configuration?
And the answer, again, depends
what dimension you live in.
In two dimensions,
there are cool ways
to reconfigure your robotic arm.
So this is actually a polygon,
a closed arm, if you will,
a closed chain, and this
is one way to unfold it.
And then, in
principle, you could
refold that into any
other shape you want.
And we will cover-- this
is one algorithm to do it.
There's actually three
algorithms to do this.
This is the most recent one.
This was originally
my Ph.D. thesis,
to figure out whether
this was possible.
It's called the
carpenter's rule problem.
This algorithm preserves the
fivefold rotational symmetry
of the polygon,
which is pretty cool.
And in general, you
take any 2D polygon,
you can unfold it while
preserving all the edge
lengths, keeping
all the connections,
and avoiding collision.
I'll show you some
other fun examples.
This is a kind of
spider, 500 vertices.
We're kind of zooming out.
As we expand here, you can see
the lengths get really tiny,
but, in reality, all the
lengths are staying the same
throughout time.
And we fold.
So this is the state
of affairs in 2D.
We have good algorithms.
It's always possible.
Universality.
So what about 3D?
3D is harder, in particular
because of examples like this.
We call this knitting needles.
You've got two blue
segments, which
you can think of
as long needles,
and then a short, purple
thread connecting them.
And there's no way to undo this.
In particular, if you started
with a straight, robotic arm,
you could not hold it in
the shape, or vice versa.
We call this a
locked configuration,
and in general lock
configurations exist,
obviously.
And we don't know how to
distinguish good or bad.
So here, we actually don't know
whether there's a good decision
algorithm or hardness, but
it's definitely not universal.
And 3D's very
interesting, because it
relates to robotic arms
in real life and protein
folding and all these things.
I'll be talking about that.
In 4D.
If you're lucky enough to
live in four dimensions,
you get universality,
everything's great.
And we'll talk about that too.
So next up, we
have paper folding.
That was our brief
overview of linkages.
So paper folding.
I'm gonna mention one problem
in the foldability world
and some problems
in the design world.
This is probably my favorite
are of paper, origami design.
But foldability's
interesting, too.
The obvious and
the first question
you might wonder about
in origami foldability
is, if what crease
patterns fold flat?
So if you take a classic
flapping bird, you unfold it,
these are the creases you get.
But in general, if I gave you
some pattern of creases drawn
on your piece of paper,
does it fold into anything?
And here, to make it
interesting, we say,
does it fold into anything flat?
Flat origami.
You have to fold
along all the creases.
Sadly, deciding this is a
problem that we call NP-hard.
So there's basically no good
algorithm to solve this,
and we will prove that in a
few classes, a few lectures.
So that was the
foldability problem.
Now onto design.
If I give you a square paper,
what shapes can I make?
That's the obvious
origami design problem.
And it turns out you
can make any polygon,
so you can make any
flat shape you want.
If you have a piece of paper
that's white on one side,
and patterned or colored
black on the other,
you can make any two-color
pattern you want.
If it's polygonal, it's
made of straight sides.
If you want to make
a 3D thing, you
could make any 3D
polyhedron, also
with two color patterns,
whatever you want.
We proved this way back in 1999.
I think it was actually
the first paper
to use the term
"computational origami."
And it's not hard to prove.
We'll prove it in a couple
of lectures, I think.
We don't have a
practical way to do this.
There is an algorithm here, but
it doesn't give you a good way
to fold anything.
And so the quest continues for
a good way to fold everything.
And one such approach
is called Origamizer.
You give it an
arbitrary 3D surface,
it designs a crease pattern.
This, you fold from a square
piece of paper-- solids are
mountains, dashed are valleys--
and you get this bunny.
This is a classic model in
computer graphics called
the Stanford bunny, and this
takes about 10 hours to fold.
If you're Tomohiro
Tachi, who designed it.
And there's free
software available
called Origamizer by Tomohiro.
And he was just here
a couple weeks ago,
and we've been proving that
this algorithm always works.
And it also seems very
practical, most of the material
here gets used in the surface.
You don't need a very
large square of paper
to make your bunny.
I have one little
example here, sort
of classic in the
origami world, which
is to make a checkerboard.
And this is a four-by-four
checkerboard, obviously not
the full eight-by-eight.
But you can fold
an eight-by-eight.
We'll talk about
different ways to do it.
This one is folded
from one square paper,
white on one side,
green on the other.
And, actually, it has a
pretty good scale factor,
just collapses by
factor of two here.
See if I can get it
back into correct state.
So there you go.
You can make your own
origami checkerboards
if you ran out of your
regular wooden ones.
Next example is what
we call maze folding.
This is the poster.
If you saw it, this is a
folding of this crease pattern,
and the design was-- In general,
you take any orthogonal graph,
meaning horizontal and
vertical lines on a grid,
and you want to extrude
that graph out of the plane,
then there's an algorithm.
It's online.
You can play with it.
I think erikdemaine.org/maze
will get you there.
You just draw that pattern.
It will give you
this crease pattern.
You print it out, and--
eight hours, maybe-- you
can fold it into realities.
So this is by [? Jenny ?] and
[? Eli, ?] who I think are
students in this class.
They got started a little early.
And I didn't bring it
here, but at some point
I will bring to the real 3D one.
So that's maze folding.
And the next one I have
is called folding cut.
This is actually the first
problem we worked on, so kind
of a personal favorite.
You take a rectangle of paper,
and then you fold it flat,
and you take your scissors and
make one complete straight cut.
This is a magic trick
performed by Harry Houdini
and other magicians, and you
get, in this case, two pieces.
And the question is,
what shapes can you
make by folding and
one straight cut?
Here I made a little one.
OK, you're not impressed,
so I'll do a harder one.
This one is actually
quite challenging to cut.
I was folding it as you were
arriving, as you probably saw.
That's about right.
It's a little hard
to open up, but this
should be the MIT logo.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: All right.
Good.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: So that's the idea.
You can impress
all your friends.
Print these out, and fold them.
It's a good challenge to fold
along the crease pattern,
and as you might guess
there's an algorithm here.
Given any polygon or
collection of polygons,
you can fold a piece
of paper to line up
all the edges in that polygon,
cut along it, you're done.
OK, that is paper
Next I want to briefly
mention polyhedra.
Actually, I have a
polyhedra right over here.
Let's just go there.
So, again, there's an unfolding
problem, and a folding problem.
And I'll start by
showing you a little bit
about the folding problem.
Oh, this shows a
little bit of both.
This a video we
made back in '99.
I was a grad student.
I had lots of hours to
make videos, animations.
So this is one example of
an unfolding of a cube.
But the unfolding we
want to consider here
is this cross unfolding
that I keep talking about.
It's kind of a classic
so fun to analyze.
So if you take that
cross shape, you
want to know what other shapes,
what other convex polyhedra,
can it fold into?
And here the rules are little
different from origami.
You have to get exactly the
surface you want no, overlap.
Here we happen to get a doubly
covered quadrilateral, which
is kind of a convex surface.
A little bit cheating.
But if we change the
creases in this way,
we get a five-sided polyhedron
with a plane of symmetry
down this axis.
Or we can change the creases in
this way and get a tetrahedron.
And it's exact coverage,
so this little tab
fits into exactly that pocket.
Exactly what you want.
As you might guess,
there's an algorithm
that will enumerate all
the different convex
polyhedra you can make from
a given polygon of paper.
And it's based on a
theorem in Russian
by Alexandrov, which is
in the background here.
If you're curious what the
Cyrillic background is,
this theorem is the
key to the algorithm.
So that's what's possible
by folding a given polygon,
and then you can
ask about unfolding.
Let me give you
a brief overview.
Unfolding.
So when you're
unfolding, you might
be interested in
only cutting along
the edges of the
surface, which is what
happened in this
cross unfolding.
Cut along these edges.
Or you might allow cutting
anywhere on the surface.
And the answers depend
on those two versions.
You could try to
convex polyhedra,
or you could try to do
arbitrary polyhedra.
So here's the story.
This one, we don't know.
This one, the answer is yes.
We'll prove it.
This one, the answer is no.
In fact, I can show
you some examples.
This is an edge unfolding
of a convex polyhedron.
The oldest set that we know
this from this 1525 book
by Albrecht Duerer.
And this is a snub cube.
He didn't have
Wikipedia at the time.
You couldn't just look
at the image and draw it.
He had to build
a physical model.
And so he cut out pieces of
paper to build physical models,
so he could paint it.
And various of his prints
have convex polyhedra in them.
And this is an example
of this open problem,
which we don't
know the answer to.
Can you edge unfold
convex polyhedra?
If you want to take non-convex
polyhedra you cannot always do
it.
This is an example of a spiky
tetrahedron that cannot be edge
unfolded.
We'll prove that.
But it can be
generally unfolded.
If you can cut anywhere, you
can find a one-piece unfolding.
And so big open
problem is, can you
do any polyhedron
with general cuts?
I think the answer is yes.
Very cool problem.
And that's polyhedra.
And the last thing I wanted to
show you is hinged dissection.
This is one more thing.
After one, two, and three, we
have four, hinged dissection.
This is a chain of blocks, which
are kind of two dimensional,
but it's not really
paper folding.
So it's like a thick
linkage between one and two,
if you will.
And this chain folds into
an equilateral triangle
or a square, and it's
over 100 years old.
Can you do anything?
Turns out there's a
universality result.
This is just a picture of
part of the proof, which
we will cover in
a later lecture.
But you can fold, you can
take any set of polygons
of the same area, there's
one chain of blocks which
will fold into each
of those polygons.
So you can get a
universality result.
You can do an equilateral
triangle to a regular hexagon
to a swan to whatever.
As long as they're all the
same area, you can do it.
And this also generalizes to 3D.
We use that to make a
little sculpture here,
little sculpture.
About 1,000 blocks, you pick up
with your gloves, these blocks,
rearrange them.
And the theorem is, you can
make any shape you want out
of the blocks by this
kind of intersection.
And that was a brief overview
of a few of the results
that we'll be talking
about in this class.
There's a lot more.
And you can check
out the 2010 web page
if you really want to know
everything that's covered,
but we'll be posting
lectures up there.
And let me know if you
have any questions.